à londres donc lui quand il quel est son
rôle
lorsque dans la procédure centralisée
c'est ça que je voulais dire
et là il se contente d'enregistrer non
même pas non non c'est ça ne passe pas
par la commission à la nfl mais dont il
parce que l'autre c'est justement la
procédure si vous voulez la procédure
centralisée à la caractéristique de d2
permettre de donner un avis puisque le
chmp donne un avis l'agencé urbaine
donne un avis ensuite c'est de la
commission après un processus de comme
idéologie maintenant qui passe par
strasbourg qui donne l'autorisation
d'habiter à découvert ces excellents les
27 états membres
ensuite effectivement il peut y avoir
des interventions spécifiques dus aux
réglementations particulières notamment
ce qui concerne la publicité ou d'autres
réglementation spécifique et il y à tout
le processus
ensuite d'accès aux marchés notamment
comportement qui lui passe effectivement
par d'autres influences donc là
notamment la commission d'admission la
commission d'amm de l'afssaps peut
s'autosaisir oui oui parce que il estime
qu' il peut d'ailleurs préféré un pgr
complémenter absolument voilà donc non
mais ça c'était donc ils aèrent et la
commission de française à mon sens doit
se saisir beaucoup plus souvent des
modalités d'utilisation et de
distribution des produits enregistrés à
l'intérieur de notre pays puisque
derrière la haie mais n'y a pas que le
marché via l'utilisation par les
personnes et donc les circuits
d'utilisation du distribution sont sous
notre responsabilité et c'est la-dessus
où l'évolution vers une commission qui
examinerait le le bénéfice-risque de
façon récurrente aux raisons sens pour
veiller à ce qu'un bien de santé sa
distribution soit adapté pas uniquement
aux risques mais au bénéfice cannes à
temps la population d'un système de
santé je voudrais redire que nous notre
pays a le plus de bénéfices mais aussi
le plus de risques puisque chez nous des
produits de santé sont très rapidement
accessible c'est beaucoup plus facile
pour certains pays de la communauté
européenne dont je participe qu'il
n'utilise
les produits de santé qu'ils
enregistrent donc effectivement ils ne
l'ont - les bénéfices et moi les risques
donc c'est un changement radical qui est
de travailler plus pour la distribution
du bien de santé on va poser une
question sur la transparence dans
laquelle je voudrais répond bien
évidemment puisque c'est une si nous
devons examiner le bénéfice-risque de
façon régulière
c'est un devoir sans ça on va laisser
passer des baisses de bénéfices et on va
laisser passer des montées de risques on
doit les examiner dans un contexte qui
est pas forcément un comparateur hit
parade entre les divers médicaments mais
s'il ya des médicaments qui tout d'un
coup sont beaucoup plus performant que
d'autres
on doit pouvoir dans l'examen du
bénéfice-risque dire bah celui-là est
d'un peu moins de bénéfices parce que
les temps ont changé c'est ce qu'est le
cap sur les antilles dès meetic
donc il est paradoxal qu à une
dissociation entre les deux c'est
paradoxal et c'est difficile à
comprendre qu'avec les mêmes données
les mêmes experts extérieurs des
opinions éventuellement différentes
puissent être comprise puis ça ne veut
pas dire ce sont deux choses différentes
mais les utilisateurs nage et trouve
salah incohérent bon je pense que c'est
la même responsabilité d'examiner le
bénéfice risque en ce qui concerne le et
cela devrait être doit être indépendant
bien évidemment du financement et du
remboursement afin que des décisions
prises de distribution ne soient pas
influencés par des restrictions de
budgétaire mais c'est sur cette
appréciation que le financeur décidera
ou non ça c'est une décision d'autres
politiques et de régulation de du
système de santé
le savoir quelles valeurs qui donnent ou
non à ces produits nous nous devons
garantir que ce sont les meilleurs
produits qui sont rendus disponibles et
forcément en comparaison en interne et
en comparaison externe et ce n'est pas
stable au cours du temps
car bien évidemment nous sommes une
agence qui doit travailler son progrès
thérapeutique est ce qu on veut offrir
c'est les progrès thérapeutiques
et quand il ya progrès tu es un petit
mais généralement ça étouffe des progrès
des produits récemment la chaise un rôle
crucial
je tiens le dire sur le système de santé
car elle intègre pas que le médicament
mais le parcours thérapeutique
il n'y a aucune agence de médicaments
dans le monde s'assoit la vie etc
nous on regarde par exemple tel
médicament mais on dit pas le nombre de
pure que le doit avoir un traitement
anti-cancéreux d'accord et ça c'est la
chaise qui donne le parcours et ça
change tout en termes de régulation ça
change tout en termes d'impact et ça on
change tout en termes de risque oui
c'est le nice qui fait ce travail mais
il s'intéresse pas aux comparateurs des
médicaments il s'intéresse à l'utilité
du site dans le système de santé du
partage des biens
par exemple il peut dire il ne vaut
jamais venu à timothée rapide en cancer
de la prostate
même si un médicament qui est
enregistrée bon où il faut le faire que
dans 5 % d'écart
bon ça c'est pas le rôle d'une agence du
médicament aujourd'hui médicaments elle
doit vérifier que ce médicament dans le
cancer de la prostate a une bonne
relation bénéfice risque dans un
contexte et son rôle n'est pas de dire
combien de qu on doit faire et à quel
coût groupes de population on doit
d'adresser ça c'est forcément une
autorité qui est indépendant du
médicament et qui regarde le bénéfice
global c'est le nike pour des raisons
essentiellement économiques
parfois ça fait un débat public en
angleterre mais qu'un système de santé
une sociologie un peu différentes voies
qu'ils ont l'air de râler mais ils ont
moins de déficit que nous quand même ça
c'est une madame blandas je vous
pardonne mais je oublié vous m'aviez
demandé
excusez moi ça va obliger une petite
gymnastique de retour en arrière mais ce
serait ponctuelle sur sa chaise
sur les commissions vous nous avez dit
l'évolution éthique des protocoles etc
vous avez dit les conflits d'intérêts
sont affichées mais est-ce que des
conséquences en soient tirées
d'exclusion de certains débats des
personnes ayant des liens
voilà oui je parle pas de l'époque du
médiateur je parle maintenant oui mais
voilà c'est ça oui la deuxième chose est
ce que vous êtes favorable ou non à une
proposition du grenelle et auquel vous
avez par ailleurs participé qui a été
voté par le parlement d'une instance
extérieure chargé de vérifier que les
agences respectent bien leurs protocoles
éthique en quelque sorte
actualisation des conflits d'intérêts
etc beaucoup de travaux sont en cours et
sur ce sujet et je crois qu'il est très
important toutes les agences financé par
l'état et quel que soit leur domaine d
expertise
un sport qui va devenir nationale est
dangereux et la contestation de
l'expertisé publique
donc nous devons nous prêter à ces
règles là je voudrais rajouter une forme
d' expertise que vous avez donc on a
soutenu ensemble dans le cadre du
grenelle et je sais qu'ils y est attaché
aussi celle expertise citoyenne parce
que les débats entre experts
pharmacologue c'est intéressant mais au
bout d'un moment il faut arrêter
et c'est très important qu'il y ait une
expertise citoyenne qui aident ou du
moins qui donne son regard voire même
son expertise aux états unis vous ne
l'ignorez pas il ya rome et dans les
agences
ce qu'on appelle les patientes atocas
six groupes qui sont des personnes
formées pour résister aux pressions des
grands savants aux pressions
éventuellement des parties prenantes aux
pressions des politiques et y
participent aux débats qui sont capables
de lire un dossier qu'en dix ans mais
finalement c'est pas si intéressant que
ça pour les patients donc je vais voter
contre
donc ça change un peu la donne on ne
sait pas si on a vraiment l'intention
j'ai vraiment l'intention d'essayer de
l'expérimenté en france
par contre le débat citoyen et déjà bien
organisé par ailleurs mais je crois
qu'on a tendance
lorsqu'on parle devant les citoyens les
experts ce ne peuvent pas avoir la même
voie et je crois qu'il faut pas mélanger
des citoyens et les parties prenantes
il est légitime faut savoir que quand on
a une commission quand on examine un
mail un médicament sur la mucoviscidose
il est normal que l'association de lutte
contre le mais qu ici deux soient
présentes mais à ce moment là elle est
partie prenante elle n'est pas notre
bien évidemment parce qu'elle y tient
voilà merci bien alors justement
puisqu'on est revenu sur les experts
pensez vous qu'il faut sanctionner les
experts qui ne publient pas leurs liens
d'intérêts ou qui font de fausses
déclarations ou qui font des oublis ou
etc
c'est à l'évidence une faute grave
puisque c'est une actuellement il ya
puisque cinq sûr puisque c'est une
tromperie
je peux vous dire que dans la communauté
scientifique internationale
c'est certainement française au cinéma
international c'est une règle d'or
risque d'être mali complètement de la
communauté scientifique parce que ça
s'est déjà produit c'est toujours
lorsqu'on l'autre n'est fait une
déclaration trompeuse
il connaît signé un article est orientée
sur un type de pratique c'est une faute
très grave
bon lui il faut que tout le monde aussi
balayer devant chez soi quand ce sont
des universitaires c'est important aussi
que la déontologie de l'université
puisse s'exercer ce qu'ils remettent en
question aussi la qualité des
ontologique de l'université donc la
sanction oui je crois qu'il faudra une
sanction
je crois que vous avez vais aussi une
proposition importante la
démocratisation hausse et d'un sous
forme d'un amendement qui rappellerait
le sunshine act
il est quand même très important qui est
aussi une des formes la démocratisation
aux états unis si les gens sont payés il
faut que ça se sache
et puis voilà quoi
et quand on est payé on est payé et puis
quand on est payé c'est à dire qu'on est
vendu mais enfin c'est important que
tout le monde sache par claude et payer
pour quoi faire
absolument mais je pense qu'il ya un
relatif consensus je dirais même les
laboratoires que nous avons interrogé le
lem que dante interrogées est favorable
à ce que soit rendue publique
les liens d'intérêts qu'il peut avoir
avec les médecins qui le siège
d'ailleurs à l'afssaps ou qui n'ai
aucune fonction dans aucune agence à ski
parce que effectivement ces médecins
aujourd'hui on connaît pas leurs liens
d'intérêts devraient donc il est
nécessaire
alors là j'ai appris en algérie qu on
avait quand même on est en avance sur
les états unis puisque eux ils n'ont pas
il n'est pas obligatoire pour les
laboratoires de publier les liens qu'ils
ont avec les associations sais c'est pas
c'est pas alors que sur ce plan j'ai été
très étonné parce que je conseille qu'
on était très en retard par rapport à l'
mais non il ne semble pas en tout cas je
pense que c'est dans cette voie qu'il
faut qu'il faut effectivement s'orienter
je dirais même mais je pense que le
ministre l'a dit lui même je pense qu'il
faut il faut aussi je sais pas s'il est
vivant tout cas je pense que les les
sociétés savantes doivent aussi un aussi
me semble-t-il publier leurs liens
d'intérêts parce qu'on s'est aperçu que
sans les laboratoires elle n'aurait pas
de elle n'aura pas d'existence elle ne
pourrait pas gérer pour ça je
m'interroge le joaillier a que lala
l'université descartes faisait un grand
un grand colloque oui sur la sur la
démocratie demain donc ya pas de
sponsors ils arrivent à faire des
colloques cents à 19 heures l'as outils
je sais pas comment ils y arrivent parce
que je les médecins sont incapables de
se rencontrer ou de fer dvd colloque
sans l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est ça
qui est 7e
écoutez moi gg j'ai rencontré beaucoup
d'experts qui m'ont dit mais si on
n'avait pas la faire de l'industrie on
ne pourrait pas nous rendre au congrès
qui qui est auquel nous devons
participer
donc il ya là effectivement un problème
une carence de l'état
je remarque si vous permettez le
déclarer ça change tout il ya beaucoup
de congrès qui sont effectivement qu'ils
ne peuvent pas exister surtout à
l'échelle mondiale sans le sponsor de
l'industrie pharmaceutique c'est pas une
nouveauté bon c'est concret sur une
prison plus mondiaux mais là aussi c'est
une déclaration d'intérêts on sait dans
mon champ de spécialité que lascaux par
exemple un grand congrès bon c'est un
congrès c'est un salon en fait un
festival de cannes ya des sponsors aussi
comme le medec par exemple voilà
mais il n'ya pas donc c'est un salon et
on présente les nouveaux produits
éventuellement la bourse va monter ou
descendre
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'ils aient pas
des des sessions scientifiques
extrêmement puissante et de traits de
très bon niveau comme au festival de
cannes on peut trouver des oeuvres de
créateurs inconnus
donc c'est un peu ça compensait par la
sécu le festival de cannes non non non
mais la scuderia ces pays parce que nous
n'avons subi ça n'aurait aucun appui sur
les balais nous n'avons aucune raison de
penser il ya quand même des lourds
public son avis sur les bancs publics en
avant que mme intérêt à financer la
participation à des grands salons
internationaux d'accord sur sur l'argent
de la solidarité nationale
je suis dépité nation parce que l'argent
dont dispose il à bord at war il vient
de chez vous c'est quand même un peu
l'argent public non parce que si les
médicaments n'étaient pas remboursés par
la sécurité sociale je pense qu' il
n'aurait pas autant de moyens pour
financer les nombreux colloques et la
publicité et la promotion se fait donc
je crois qu'il faut pas se tromper ce
que vous défendez que je partage ces cas
ne fait singulièrement donc on pourrait
très vite et qu'il faut qu'on soit très
clair sur les liens d'intérêts vous avez
mentionné les sociétés savantes
en fait que c'est quoi créer une société
savante s'est créé une association loi
personne ne vérifie le caractère sa
vente de la société d'accord donc on
peut se proclamer une société savante
sans forcément qui est une règle qui
soit admise et c'est peut-être bien
comme ça ensuite que les sociétés
savantes sollicite de l'argent public
pour exercer sa mission sa vente
pourquoi pas organiser des colloques
dans le cas de l'université ce n'est
peut-être pas totalement interdit donc
dans les déclarations que vous allez
demander aux firmes sur les fonds
qu'elles versent vous aurez aussi un
accès aux déclaré à l'argent qu'elle
verse aux sociétés qui organise des
congrès à paris ou dans le monde
j'ai toujours il aura alors l'occasion
peut-être de je crois que c'est
important que la transparence soit faite
donc les sociétés savantes peuvent vivre
avec de l'argent public
modestement ça peut venir dans ce camp
on dit que ces armes en lituanie mais ça
peut venir la nuit d'autant plus que ce
que je sache paris est la première ville
de concret aux mondiaux indoor l'instant
j'essaie très prisée pour les français
mais c'est mais c'est quand même pas
mais il faut que tout se sait dia soit
en ce qui concerne les fonctionnaires
comme moi ou comme les fonctionnaires de
la vie'' quand ils vont à lascaux il
s'exprime pas au nom de l'amitié il
reste à côté ils sont pas invités c'est
comme ça c'est normal il n'y a pas de
liens d'intérêts qu'ils puissent être
par contre qui s'intéresse aux
communications scientifiques où la
veille étaient présentés dans ce type de
colloques
je crois que c'est un devoir que
honnêtement
donc il faut limiter effectivement les
financements par l'industrie
pharmaceutique est financée de façon
beaucoup plus explicite des sociétés
savantes qui prennent des règles
déontologiques
ils n'acceptent pas d'argent de
publicité au sein krauth un gros travail
comme vous savez dans l'édition
scientifique
il ya un phénomène mondial qui est
magnifique qui s'appelle plos public
library of science
d'accord ou les plus grands
scientifiques du monde entier se sont
associés pour faire des voeux une revue
totalement indépendante du financement
de l'industrie pharmaceutique
donc ce n'est pas interdit pour les
collègues qui veulent publier un très
bon niveau
ils sont pas obligés de passer par des
revenus sécurisés par l'industrie
pharmaceutique
donc les clubs l'éclairage en gros il
faut que dans les revues ou dans les
congrès on sache qui fait quoi et au nom
de qui on parle
il n'y a pas d'entente de dire je je
suis porte parole de tels chiens on va
pas mais le tout c'est de le dire quand
on voit que ça toi de la pseudo trainer
sais c'est plutôt une marque de qualité
et de vous connaissez lourds man oui je
connais mon mari je suis de marseille
est allé quelques fois en septembre je
serai d'une voix lente et un retourné là
maintenant vous avez ici en général 6 6
jeux si je vais à lourmarin ces
pourparlers pour essayer de porter la
saga ya pas dans les huit le sait pas où
la considère pas si j'ai ce problème
mais on n'est pas obligé d'avaler la
cuisine industrie pharmaceutique
on peut porter une voie publique il ya
un deuxième coloris sont très ils sont
très forts sont de grands professionnels
on n'a même pas à madame je salue
l'arrivée de madame la rapporteure
que j'aie supplée essayer de supplier
tant bien que mal et qui maintenant va
pouvoir enfin vous posez ces questions
je vous en prie va chez le sénateur ya
un deuxième colloque important qui
s'appelle bien le le colloque de gien
haïtiens qui suit le colloque de
lourmarin
je ne connaissais pas toujours un vvf il
est financé par la salle
c'est par l'inserm et tous les
chercheurs tous les industriels aussi
son présent semblent ils mangent à la
même cafétéria et les choses peuvent se
faire de façon très vous n'habitez
jamais par exemple les industriels bien
sûr ils viennent à la bsat les colloques
pour mai un colloque qui s'est assuré
anisé par l'afssaps et bien sûr vous qui
allez madame pas bien après l'exemple
madame bartoli oui oui non juste un
exemple pour vous comprends ce genre
d'initiative à saint denis
donc vous invitons dans nos locaux ont
fait très régulièrement par exemple une
journée portes ouvertes pour les pme
innovantes époux on a fait également
dans une journée pour les académies
innovants et toutes les équipes
académiques justement qui font de la
recherche appliquée ou de la recherche
clinique dans le domaine des produits de
santé et l'a donc nous invitons c'est
absolument gratuits à se limite c'est
évidemment la place disponible a sans
doute n'est pas illimité quant à elle
est donc là tout le monde vient on les
nourrit vous n'allez pas d'aller dans
les stations
mahler ou exotique très bon l'avant at
war c'est à saint denis un nom voilà on
est soucieux de préserver dépenses
publiques
oui quand on a dit oui alors que pour
les labos sont pas des effectivement
cédé sont libres devant le répondent de
leurs dépenses devant leurs actions
futures
ça c'est un handicap insurmontable bien
alors madame la important puisque vous
êtes là peut-être que vous pourriez en
profiter pour vous exprimer
je voudrais m'excuser commission des
affaires sociales sur le projet de loi
de bioéthique on était enfermé depuis
14h30
j'ai cru bon au sortir de cette réunion
venir pour voir si la réunion était vous
étiez au début de cette réunion mais le
président voir si cette réunion était
fini et d'abord m'excuser auprès du
directeur de l'afssa ce des
fonctionnaires et un collègue mais donc
je ne sais pas quelles sont les
questions qui a été posé simplement vous
le dis tu connais une qui n'a pas été
posée que j'aimerais bien posée est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire quelle est la
procédure habituelle de remonter
traitement de l'information entre
l'agent chargé du médicament et le
gouvernement sur les effets indésirables
de médicaments
c'est à dire la la la la la direction gé
parce que c'est certain nombre de
ministres auditionnés on dit on affirmé
ne pas avoir été informés sur le
médiator et moi je voudrais qu'on
voudrait connaître la procédure oui de
remontée du traitement d'informations
entre l'agencé le gouvernement quant aux
quelque part vous avez une indication
une suspicion des faits d'effets
indésirables de médicaments alors déjà
pour commencer si vous voulez la
direction générale de la santé présente
dans toutes les commissions qui lui qui
donc à la commission nationale de
pharmacovigilance par exemple la
commission d'autorisation de mise sur le
marché a conquis son public c'est donc
de ce fait si vous voulez le
représentant de la direction générale de
la santé donc doit signaler est en tout
cas est là pour entendre il faire
entendre éventuellement sa voix dans ses
différents instant c est par ailleurs
lorsqu il y a un doute sur des
indications et bien l' agence a été
créée pour prendre des décisions au nom
de l'état et donc dans ce cas il y à des
informations si vous voulez qu'ils sont
donnés légèrement en amont sur les
tenants et les aboutissants des
décisions sensibles que l' agence doit
prendre mais effectivement elle est
tenue de par ses missions inscrit dans
la loi de prendre ses décisions au nom
de l'état
voilà pour les travaux de la mission
d'information sur le médiator
hier le sénat a adopté en seconde
lecture une proposition de loi sur le
prix du livre numérique
ce texte co rédigé par jacques legendre
président de la commission de la culture
ici au sénat et catherine dumas
sénatrice ump de paris prévoit que les
éditeurs fixent un prix unique de vente
au public pour le livre numérique comme
c'est déjà le cas pour le livre papier
depuis la loi lang de 1981 c'est donc
une partie de la discussion de ce texte
que je vous propose de voir tout de
suite
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi modifié par
l'assemblée nationale relative au prix
du livre numérique dans la discussion
générale la parole et à monsieur
frédéric mitterrand ministre de la
culture et de la communication ce
ministre
je vais bien
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission de la culture
de l'éducation et de la communication
sert jacques legendre
madame le rapporteur cher colette mélot
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
célébrerons cette année 2011 les 30 ans
de la loi du 10 août 1981 relatives aux
prix unique du livre numérique
cette loi dont le célèbre éditeur jérôme
lindon l'un de ses premiers et courageux
défenseur souligne à assise juste titre
qu'elle n'était pas tant une question
juridique ou économique qu'une affaire
de civilisation
nous savons à quel point cette
régulation a contribué à préserver la
diversité culturelle et la créativité
éditorial tout en accompagnant la
croissance quasi continue du marché du
livre français depuis 30 ans nous savons
le rôle joué par cette loi pour
permettre à tous les réseaux de vente au
détail de coexister en premier lieu les
3500 librairies indépendantes
nous savons aussi que le prix fixe du
livre je crois utile de le rappeler dans
le contexte actuel est favorable aux
consommateurs que je préfère pour ma
part de loin ap les lecteurs disposer
d'une offre riche et varié et non d'un
choix standardisés réduit à quelques
best-sellers quelle que soit leur
qualité voilà l'intérêt du lecteur
et ce d'autant que la loi lang du 10
août 1981 loi fondatrice pour la
régulation des industries culturelles
qui a inspiré près de la moitié des pays
de l'union européenne n'a pas eu d'effet
inflationniste et qu'elle s'est révélée
en fait compatible avec une large gamme
de tarifs ainsi le prix d'un livre de
poche et il en moyenne de 6 euros
notre responsabilité collective est à
présent de faire vivre cette loi de
civilisation à l'heure numérique
je tiens par conséquent a salué
l'attention soutenue que la
représentation nationale
notamment au sein de cette haute
assemblée
porte un tel enjeu la proposition de loi
sur le prix unique du livre numérique
dans madame la sénatrice catherine dumas
et monsieur le président le gendre on
tue l'initiative nous fournit l'occasion
de définir le cadre de régulation
indispensable pour accompagner la chaîne
du livre dans un processus de
transformation sans précédent depuis
l'invention de l'imprimerie par
gutenberg
il y a cinq siècles j'ai effectué au
début du mois un déplacement aux états
unis
riche de bien des enseignements sur la
formidable transformation dans laquelle
nous sommes d'ores et déjà engagé j'en
retiens notamment les effets
dévastateurs une concurrence sauvage sur
le marché du livre numérique illustré à
l'occasion de la guerre des prix
exacerbée que se sont livrés les
principaux réseaux de vente de livres
numériques aux états unis en 2009 2010
cette dernière a conduit certains
opérateurs à pratiquer de considérables
rabais voir des ventes à perte d'âme
ping sur les meilleures ventes au
détriment des équilibres de l'ensemble
de la chaîne du livre
mais l'effort de régulation de
structuration du marché entrepris
récemment aux états unis méritent aussi
d'être souligné comme vous le savez
depuis 2010 les plus grands éditeurs
américains ont obtenu le passage au
système du contrat d' agences ou
l'éditeur contrôles sont pris avec
l'appui notable de google et d'apple
contrairement aux prédictions alarmistes
ce changement de modèle économique n'a
entraîné aucun fléchissement du marché
qui bien au contraire a continué sa
croissance soutenue
il est clair dans ce contexte que
l'objectif consistant à préserver la
diversité éditoriale en prenant appui
sur un riche réseau de détaillants reste
pleinement d'actualité à l'heure
numérique
s'il est normal que l'arrivée du
numérique s'accompagne transfert de
valeur al'avantage d'acteurs nouveaux
nous devons veiller à ce que cette
transformation n'aboutissent pas
une baisse globale de la valeur produite
comme ce fut le cas pour la musique il
convient d'éviter que des acteurs en
position de force n'impose des
conditions défavorables à toute la
chaîne du livre
il convient aussi de défense à l'heure
numérique le rôle essentiel de
médiateurs culturels joué par les
libraires pour qui le livre ne se réduit
pas un produit d'appel dans ces
conditions une régulation est plus que
jamais nécessaire
il nous faut naturellement l'adapter à
l'air et à la réalité de ce nouveau
marché notamment en la cible en sur le
livre homothétique lequel devrait
représenter l'essentiel du marché du
livre numérique dans les quatre ou cinq
prochaines années mais son intervention
un stade précoce est la meilleure
garantie que le développement du marché
s'effectue dans des conditions
harmonieuse sans captation de la valeur
par des acteurs dominants
j'ajoute qu'il est tout à fait normal et
même tout à fait souhaitable que les
éditeurs soient en mesure de contrôler
la valeur du livre quel que soit quel
que soit le lieu d'implantation du
diffuseur afin d'assurer la cohérence du
dispositif proposé en évitant les
risques de contournement
ce principe doit s'appliquer à
l'ensemble des ventes de livres
numériques effectuées en france
je rejoins donc entièrement l'objectif
que les distributeurs établis en france
puis se jouer à armes égales avec ceux
établis hors de nos frontières
il serait en effet paradoxal que
certaines plateformes de distribution de
livres numériques échappe à une
régulation de cette nature lorsqu'elle
s'adresse à des lecteurs français
il est parfaitement normal cependant
qu'il y ait un débat y compris entre les
deux chambres sur la meilleure stratégie
à retenir pour atteindre cet objectif
partagé partagé par l'ensemble de la
filière
nous savons que le contrat de mandat a
pour effet de restreindre l'autonomie du
détaillant et donc le rôle de médiation
culturelle des libraires
malgré certains cons
régnant ce modèle a fait ses preuves aux
états unis notamment à l'égard des
grands opérateurs de l'internet
par ailleurs comme vous le savez ce
sujet est suivie avec une grande
attention par la commission européenne
qui a rendu deux avis très réservé sur
la proposition de lois françaises
nous devons donc avoir conscience des
interrogations sérieuses que l' approche
développée ici peut soulever
du côté de la commission européenne
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement entend poursuivre le
dialogue entamé depuis plusieurs mois
déjà avec les institutions européennes
attentif aux remarques et aux
interrogations légitimes de la
commission européenne le gouvernement
fera valoir en particulier par une
analyse juridique et microéconomiques
très rigoureuse que la loi sur le prix
unique du livre numérique répond à un
enjeu crucial de diversité culturelle la
préservation de la diversité culturelle
consacré par la convention de l'unesco
mais aussi par les traités et la
jurisprudence européenne est un principe
cardinal auquel il nous faut donner
toute sa portée
à l'heure du numérique à l'image du
conseil culture informel où je me suis
rendu ce lundi en hongrie
je défendrai donc avec force l'idée que
dans l'univers physique comme sur
internet le livre demeure un objet
culturel singulier irréductible à sa
seule dimension commerciale sans me
prononcer sur le fond de la procédure d'
enquête récemment engagé par la
commission
je ne manquerai pas dans le cadre de ce
dialogue de souligner à tout le moins
mon étonnement devant la disproportion
des moyens employés
alors que le marché du livre numérique
est au juste naissant cette initiative a
pu être perçu comme une manifestation
d'hostilité sans précédent à l'égard
d'acteurs majeurs du monde culturel
je comprends ce sentiment est dite et la
pléiade
milan kundera umberto eco ou günther
grass ce n'est pas
vendre des voitures trafiquées
n'oublions pas que le socle de la
civilisation européenne
c'est sa capacité de marier les crient
au génie de la diversité je n'accepte
donc pas l'idée que les grands
supermarchés numérique étranger à toute
préoccupation de diversité éditoriale et
de rémunération de la création soit le
seul visage du marché intérieur
culturelle dans ce soi-disant paradis du
consommateur qui découvrira qui fera
partager les julien gracq de demain qui
resta toute sa vie fidèle un éditeur
modeste qui se trouvait tout près dix
sites au luxembourg josé corti
n'oublions pas que les découvertes sont
le plus souvent le fait de libraires
indépendants les grands et d'éditeurs
indépendants les grands réseaux y
compris numérique ne faisant
qu'amplifier le mouvement
une fois qu'il a été lancé aux marchés
dérégulés qui au nom d'une vision très
abstraite de l'intérêt du consommateur
fait le jeu de certains acteurs acteurs
à prétention hégémonique pour lesquels
le livre n'est qu'un produit d'appel
l'europe se doit de préférer le
développement équilibré de l'écosystème
des industries créatives et le soutien à
la compétitivité des acteurs industriels
européens ce qui passe aussi et
d'ailleurs je m'y emploie fortement par
une tva à taux réduit pour le livre
numérique
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs la
proposition de loi examinée ce soir ne
créera pas les conditions d'une économie
de rente pour certains acteurs mais
celle du développement d'une offre
légale abondante attractive pour le
lecteur tout en préservant une assiette
stable de rémunération pour les ayants
droit en particulier les auteurs qui
doivent pleinement bénéficier de cette
nouvelle frontière du monde de l'édition
je regrette donc les discussions
entreprises depuis plusieurs mois entre
auteurs et éditeurs et été interrompu à
l'orée du salon du livre
alors que d'importantes avancées
paraissait à portée de main il n'est pas
interdit de se demander à ce
des gars si la loi ne devrait pas
sanctionner très vite les résultats les
plus solides de ces discussions
je pense aux avancées les plus
susceptibles d'enrichir notre code de la
propriété intellectuelle
lequel s'il mérite d'être adapté au
monde numérique ne peut l'être qu'après
une instruction rigoureuse par les
pouvoirs publics
dans tous les cas j'invite les parties à
reprendre leurs discussions et les
négociations le plus rapidement possible
bien entendu cette proposition de loi
trouve sa place
une place éminente dans la stratégie
globale sur le livre numérique mise en
oeuvre par le gouvernement et dont vous
connaissez les grands axes canton
proclama que la bibliothèque comprenait
tous les livres la première réaction fut
un bonheur extravagant tous les hommes
se sentir maître d'un trésor intacte et
secret oh certes nous sommes encore loin
de l'utopie babélienne explorée par
aurait luis borgès vous le savez
cependant la france est le seul pays
d'europe à avoir mis en place un système
de financement ambitions de numérisation
des livres
d'un montant de 10 millions d'euros par
an qui a permis de numériser d'une part
les fonds patrimoniaux de la
bibliothèque nationale de france plus
d'un vil 2 millions de documents sont à
ce jour disponibles dans gallica
d'autre part les catalogues papiers
vivent des éditeurs soit à ce jour un
total de 600 mille titres
j'ai également eu le plaisir de signer
il ya quelques semaines avec rené ricol
commissaire général à l'investissement
et les professionnels concernés
un accord cadre de portée historique qui
permettra la numérisation de 500 mille
livres du 20ème siècle un disponible
dans les librairies
compte tenu notamment de la difficulté
de réactualiser les contrats de manière
simple pour les éditeurs alors que la
justice américaine vient de rejeter le
projet d'accord entre google et les
auteurs et éditeurs de ce pays
concernant l'exploitation de plusieurs
millions d'oeuvres protégées
la stratégie ainsi mises en oeuvre en
france par le ministère et les
professionnels français du livre pour
favoriser la diffusion des oeuvres dans
l'univers numérique tout en respectant
le droit d'auteur se trouve de ce fait
pleinement conforter outre l'action en
faveur de la lecture en lien avec les
bibliothèques et les médiathèques de nos
territoires à travers les 14
propositions de mon plan lecture et le
soutien à près de 500 libraires
indépendants à travers le libraire le
label libraire indépendant de référence
j'ai placé également l'adaptation de la
librairie traditionnelle au numérique au
coeur de mes priorités
je m'attache ainsi à soutenir via le
centre national du livre
le projet 1000 une librairie point com
qui entend fédérer sur internet l'offre
du plus grand nombre de libraires
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
l'heure du capitalisme cognitif en
quelque sorte et des formidables
transformations liées au numérique
l'adaptation de l'écosystème du livre
doit être accompagnée par les pouvoirs
publics à travers une régulation
efficaces proportionnées garante de la
diversité culturelle
la proposition de loi examinée ce soir
cette loi du développement durable du
livre numérique répond à cette exigence
elle recueille donc évidemment mon plein
soutien
transposant à l'univers numérique
moyennant les adaptations nécessaires
les principes vertueux de la loi lang
ce texte constitue une contribution
essentielle à la construction civilisée
du marché du livre numérique que tous
nous appelons de nos voeux
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci monsieur ministres issus en
général la parade et à madame colette
mélot rapporteur de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation de la
communication à chaque collègue ne vous
écoute on monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la
navette législative se poursuit donc sur
cette importante proposition de loi
qu'avait déposé notre président jacques
legendre et notre collègue catherine
dumas je vous rappelle qu'il s'agit
d'accompagner la mutation du secteur du
livre caractérisée par l'émergence du
livre numérique
en effet l'ensemble des filières
culturelles sont désormais concernés par
ces véritable révolution des modes de
création de diffusion et de consommation
même si le terme n'est pas très
approprié des biens culturels avec
internet et avec le développement du
processus de dématérialisation qu'il
entraîne voici quelques jours pour sont
pour son 30e anniversaire le salon du
livre a réuni à paris 180 mille
visiteurs en quatre jours
le succès de cette grande opportunité
annuel des changes entre les
professionnels et le grand public ne se
dément pas
preuve de la vitalité de ce secteur
culturel parallèlement le salon permet
de débattre des évolutions en cours
ainsi pour la quatrième année
consécutive le salon du livre a présenté
un espace consacré à l'édition numérique
et à la lecture sur support mobile
ses organisateurs affirmant que
désormais la question n'est plus de
savoir si le livre sera ou non numérique
mais bel et bien d'en saisir
concrètement toutes les opportunités et
les enjeux c'est parce que les
parlementaires en sont bien conscients
qu'ils souhaitent adopter une régulation
adaptée de ce nouveau marché
il s'agit d'encourager le développement
de l'offre légale de livres
eric d'accompagner et d'encadrer sa
montée en puissance tout en favorisant
l'atteinte des objectifs suivants d'une
part promouvoir la diversité culturelle
et linguistique notamment un application
de la convention de l'unesco
ce qui suppose le maintien de la
richesse de l'offre éditoriale et de sa
mise en valeur à l'égard des lecteurs
d'autre part respecter une concurrence
loyale non susceptible de conduire à une
concentration excessive du marché de la
librairie numérique
à cette fin les libraires physique qui
contribuent au maillage culturel de
notre territoire doivent pouvoir aussi
exister dans des conditions viables sur
ce nouveau marché et je suis très bien
entendu l'objectif relatif au respect du
droit d'auteur la propriété
intellectuelle devant demeurer la clé de
voûte de l'édition les éditeurs doivent
conserver un rôle central dans la
détermination des prix comme le prévoit
le texte qui applique ce principe au
livre numérique dit homothétique nous
savons tous que d'autres types d'oeuvres
numériques fleurir au mais les règles de
concurrence ne semble pas permettre à ce
stade de les viser je vous rappelle
qu'après notre adoption du texte en
première lecture le 26 octobre 2010
l'assemblée nationale l'a examiné le 15
février dernier elle a adopté des
modifications de porter rédactionnelle à
l'article 1er qui définit le livre
numérique et le champ d'application de
la loi et à l'article 5 qui régit les
relations commerciales entre éditeurs et
détaillants
elle a adopté conforme les articles 4
relatif aux ventes à prime 6 sur les
sanctions et 8 qui prévoit les modalités
d'application du texte
outre mer à l'article 2 relatif au
principe de fixation des prix de vente
par l'éditeur en premier lieu elle est
revenue à la rédaction initiale du
premier alinéa c'est-à-dire à
l'application du texte osseuse éditeurs
établis en france
j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure en second
lieu elle a introduit
dispositif consensuel qui n'avaient pas
pu être trouvé avec les professionnels à
l'occasion de notre première lecture
afin d'instituer une exception au
principe de la fixation du prix de vente
par l'éditeur ap l'ip applicable aux
seuls livres numériques intégrés dans
des offres composites spécifique destiné
à un usage collectif et dans un but de
recherche ou d'enseignement supérieur
notre commission a adopté cette
disposition qui concerne notamment les
éditeurs scientifiques à l'article 3 qui
impose aux libraires de respecter le
prix de vente fixé par l'éditeur
les députés sont revenus au texte de la
proposition initiale en ne visant que
libraire établis en france alors qu'à
l'initiative de notre collègue jean
pierre leleux nous avions à l'unanimité
décidé que la pleine efficacité du
dispositif suppose et son application à
l'ensemble des libraires exerçant sur
leur activité sur le territoire national
par ailleurs nos collègues députés ont
complété l'article 7 qui prévoit un
rapport annuel au parlement en prévoyant
un comité de suivi est un développement
spécifique dudit rapport sur le droit
d'auteur
il s'agit là d'une faible contrepartie à
leur suppression de l'article 5bis
article que nous avions adopté à
l'unanimité
à l'initiative de notre collègue david
assouline en vue de garantir une
rémunération des auteurs tenant compte
de l'économie résultant du recours à
l'édition numérique
enfin l'assemblée nationale a introduit
à l'article 9-1 adoptant deux
amendements identiques de son rapporteur
le servait démarre et du groupe
socialiste
il s'agit d'une validation législative
en faveur du mécénat culturel
cette disposition concerne permis de
construire dans l'enceinte du jardin
d'acclimatation à paris afin de
permettre la poursuite de la
construction du musée d'art contemporain
édifié par une fondation d'entreprise
un effet le motif d'annulation de ce
permis de construire tient exclusivement
à ce qu'une simple allées intérieures du
jardin a été bien que n'étant ni
routière ni circulantes considéré comme
une voie ce qu'elle n'a pas au sens des
règlements d'urbanisme
enfin je précise que outre son caractère
d'intérêt général
cet article est conforme aux exigences
posées par le conseil constitutionnel en
matière de validation législative depuis
notre premier examen du texte deux
événements sont intervenus les avis
circonstancié de la commission
européenne suite aux notifications par
le gouvernement de la proposition de loi
initiale puis du texte voté par le sénat
et l'opération conduite chez certains
éditeurs par les actifs par les
autorités européennes et françaises de
la concurrence pour vérifier que leurs
pratiques ne sont pas susceptibles de
relever du l'entente cette démarche
illustre la brutalité des rapports de
forces en présence sur le marché des
oeuvres culturelles numériques en
particulier au sein de l'oligopole
américain constitué d'amazon d'apple et
google avec des méthodes trop souvent
prédatrice la commission européenne a
émis des réserves dans ces deux avis
donc sur les deux textes évoqués elle
conclut de ces analyses que la
proposition de loi pourrait restreindre
la liberté d'établissement et la libre
prestation de services et être également
incompatible avec certaines dispositions
de la directive services et de la
directive de la directive e-commerce
elle ajoute que dans la mesure où un
objectif de diversité culturelle
pourrait justifier l'une des
restrictions de la liberté
d'établissement et de la libre
prestation de services potentiellement
imposé par la proposition de loi ces
restrictions ne semble pas appropriée
pour atteindre des objectifs de
diversité culturelle et ne sont pas
proportionnels à ses objectifs nous
avons cependant relevé que la commission
européenne n'avait pas fermé la porte
elle a émis des
m certes forte mais a aussi posé au
gouvernement français une série de
questions certaines d'ordre général
d'autres relatives au droit de la
concurrence qui devrait permettre de les
lever
ceci suppose un volontarisme politique
fort à la fois du parlement et du
gouvernement ainsi qu'une présentation
complète claire des objectifs du texte
ainsi que l'apport des preuves
éclaircissements attendu par la
commission sur les différents points
relevés en particulier pour justifier le
respect des principes de l'adéquation
c'est à dire de la nécessité et de la
proportionnalité entre les objectifs de
la proposition de loi et les moyens
choisis pour les atteindre les points de
divergence avec nos collègues députés
recouvre de questions en premier lieu
celle de l'adoption ou non d'une clause
d'extraterritorialité
concernant les éditeurs de livres
numériques d'une part à l'article 2 et
les libraires
d'autre part à l'article 3 à cet égard
notre commission a rétabli les
dispositions votées par le sénat à
l'unanimité en première lecture sur la
proposition de notre collègue
jean-pierre le lieu la seconde question
concerne le droit d'auteur en raison de
la suppression par l'assemblée nationale
de l'article 5 bis que nous avions
introduit sur la proposition de notre
collègue david assouline
notre commission a également rétabli cet
article afin de mieux encadrer les
négociations entre éditeurs et auteurs
ces derniers étant souvent dans un
rapport de force défavorable pour
obtenir une rémunération équitable en
cas d'exploitation numérique de leurs
oeuvres
le conseil permanent des écrivains et le
syndicat national de l'édition ont
engagé des négociations
interprofessionnelles depuis quelques
mois
si l'on peut se féliciter de certaines
avancées
il semble en revanche qu'ils ne soient
pas parvenus à un accord sur des sujets
majeurs tels que la durée du contrat et
les conditions de rémunération
un cadrage par le législateur
reste donc d'actualité je vous propose
de suivre notre commission qui a
travaillé dans un esprit très
constructif au service de l'efficacité
et du pragmatisme genre m r si tous mes
collègues et en particulier notre
président jacques legendre que ce sujet
passionne également comme nous l'avons
encore constatés à l'occasion de la
table ronde que nous avons organisé le 9
mars dernier avec différents acteurs de
la filière
ce texte est très attendu par les
professionnels
il s'inscrit dans un ensemble de
réflexions est en quelque sorte de
combat en faveur de l'écrit et de sa
diffusion des technologies numériques
devant se développer dans des conditions
telles qu'elles représentent une
opportunité plutôt qu'une menace pour
les acteurs et pour la diversité
culturelle et donc aussi pour les
lecteurs je pense en particulier à
l'alignement de la tva applicable au
livre numérique sur celle du livre
papier mais aussi aux oeuvres orphelines
ou encore au débat plus général sur
l'harmonisation des niveaux d'impôts sur
les sociétés au sein de l'union
européenne
notre mobilisation en faveur du secteur
du livre neuf l'époux pardon ne faiblira
donc pas dans les mois à venir et je
suis convaincu monsieur le ministre que
le gouvernement aura également à coeur
de sensibiliser tant les institutions
européennes que les autres états membres
sur la nécessité d'appréhender au mieux
les intérêts de l'europe dans ces
domaines je vous remercie de votre
attention
merci monsieur coloring dans la suite de
la discussion générale la parole l'état
david assouline
pour le groupe socialiste
monsieur le président ce ministre
je présente la commission de la culture
dames le rapporteur mes chers collègues
oui la diffusion du livre connaît depuis
quelques années une mutation commerciale
dont les conséquences sont loin d'être
neutres sur le plan culturel la vente du
livre a vu apparaître se développer peu
à peu de nouvelles formes de
distribution
lesquels ont engendré une concurrence
très vive qui apportaient parfois
atteinte à tout un ensemble ouvrage de
grande valeur c'est une citation que je
viens de faire
on pourrait dire que on vient de la
prononcer et c'était les mots mêmes du
ministre jacques lang pour promouvoir et
faire adopter la loi sur le prix unique
du livre qui est aujourd'hui incontesté
salué le ministre l'a encore fait tout à
l'heure et qui a montré son succès par
la pratique quand on en parle d'une
trentaine d'années après quand on sait
on peut citer la l'affluence au salon du
livre
mais le fait qu'aujourd'hui c'est 5
milliards d'euros de ventes le marché du
livre est loin d'être anecdotique
il a fallu donc à un moment donné
légiférer
or avec la révolution numérique
il y avait un espèce de trou législatif
dans lequel pouvait s'engouffrer avec la
le développement plus grands de ceux qui
restent encore à cépie phénoménal
puisque c'est un pur sang on est
important c'est déjà pas mal
ça veut dire que ça existe et quand on
voit les évolutions notamment aux états
unis s'est déjà 10% marché et bien ce
n'était pas possible pour défendre le
principe du livre du prix unique de ne
pas faire une adaptation de cette
fameuse joie de quatre ans
1 à la nouvelle donne pour qu'ils
s'appliquent aux livres numériques
ça ne veut pas dire que la chose et si
simple on adapte et tout va en mettant à
la place du livre papier on est
numérique et tout peut se faire de la
même façon qu'avant et c'est pour cela
que nous avons des débats que nous ne
sommes pas d'accord avec la façon dont
l'assemblée nationale après ou des
choses parce que quand il s'agit du
numérique nous les savons il n'y a plus
de frontières et donc il faut bien et
tenir compte de cette donne ne pas nous
replier mais en même temps défendre la
culture qui n'est pas une marchandise
comme les autres
vous avez fait une citation qui
s'apparente à celle là et il nous faut
donc à nouveau légiférer je trouve
particulièrement important qu'en la
matière il y ait du consensus politique
sur cette question il y à un consensus
politique tant au sénat qu'à l'assemblée
nationale et c'est ça qui va donner de
la force à ce que nous faisons là où il
y a plus de consensus et paradoxalement
pas entre la droite et la gauche mais
entre l'ensemble des familles politiques
du sénat est la cerise et moi je vous
obligé de dire les choses n'est pas
l'ensemble l'assemblée nationale mais
seulement l'ump je ne comprends pas
pourquoi qui a une interprétation sur
deux questions
les auteurs et sur la question de
l'extraterritorialité différente de la
nôtre
non pas qu'il ne voit pas le problème
mais ils ne veulent pas ou ils pensent
que c'est dangereux d'y répondre de la
façon dont nous avons nous décidé alors
nos collègues députés sont revenus en
effet sur deux propositions que
considérant d'un commun accord avec la
majorité comme essentielle au risque
d'initier une relation conflictuelle
avec l'assemblée nous estimons
nécessaire de les réinscrire dans le
projet de loi parce que ces deux points
constitue une réelle avancée et que leur
suppression réduire et la porte et
novatrice de ce texte et son importance
il est rare que les dispositions soient
aussi consensuel ici et je me permet de
les rappeler ça a été fait de façon
excellente par madame le rapporteur
les députés ont refusé que les
dispositions du présent texte puisse
s'appliquer aux plates formes de
distribution du livre numérique situé en
dehors du territoire national
en clair ni amazon et apple ne seraient
concernés par ces mesures que nous
prenons ensemble alors qu'ils
constituent qu'un plan mondial les plus
gros fournisseurs de ce type de contenu
autant dire que cette si cette
disposition devait uniquement viser les
entreprises françaises c'étaient les
dispositions qu'on va mettre en place
nous ne cibleront qu'une infime partie
du secteur la loi en deviendrait caduque
dans son principe et même la loi en
deviendrait dangereuse parce que les
entreprises françaises auraient des
contraintes que les autres n'auraient
pas à la rigueur je ne veux pas ça
faudrait même ne pas légiférer pour
qu'elle puisse elle s'adapte et avoir
les mêmes armes que les entreprises
étrangères
alors si on légifère il faut absolument
donner une réponse à cette question
ou sinon on peut en voulant bien faire
avoir même dégradée et empirer la
situation
je suis pour le moins surpris sur le
type d'argument selon lesquelles les
directives s'opposerait à une telle
extension parce qu'elle constituerait
une tentative pour miner la libre
concurrence et créer des entraves
protectionnisme
d'une part le prix unique du livre a
fait l'objet d' attaques par le passé je
vous le rappelle le prêt est unique du
livre
c'était pas le prix unique du livre
numérique par le passé
la taille des libéraux de tout poil qui
estimer précisément qu'il constituait un
obstacle à la libre concurrence et était
de ce fait contraire aux directives
européennes déjà
donc on our eux on nous ressort le même
argument mais sur le livre numérique
on sait que la cour de justice des
communautés européenne leur a donné tort
sur le fondement du droit à une
politique culture heureuse culturel
pardon soucieuse j'ai fait une
contraction culturel soucieuse de
maintenir la création
si le prix unique du livre appliquée sur
les territoires français à l'ensemble
des éditeurs de la planète est donc
conforme aux textes européens en vigueur
je voudrais bien savoir en quoi son
extension au livre numérique pourrait
représenter une attaque compter
directive instituant le marché européen
on n'a pas de réponse à cela la
proposition des députés contribuera à
créer deux types d'entreprises d'une
part les entreprises nationales qui
seront soumises à prix unique du livre
numérique
les entreprises étrangères qui pourront
agir comme bon leur semblera
en d'autres termes nos collègues
permettent par leur texte justement
l'extension l'existence d'une distorsion
de concurrence entre entreprises
puisqu'elles ne sont pas soumises aux
mêmes règles
paradoxalement là et bien là réelles
attaques au principe de concurrence
libre et non faussée
pourtant défendue par l'union européenne
et je ne suis pas le plus ardent
défenseur
mais en suivant cette logique c'est
exactement ce qui serait tout ce qui se
passerait la concurrence serait
complètement fausses et alors amazon en
plus est assez bien mal placée pour
donner des leçons de concurrence à qui
que ce soit bien loin d'être un acteur
d'un marché ouvert
la plateforme anglaise aussitôt au
contraire le paragons de circuit fermé
où les différentes activités sont
concentrées au sein d'un même groupe au
détriment de la diversité de l'offre et
du maintien des différents métiers de
l'édition ainsi
le groupe possède sa tablette de lecture
numérique le fameux kindle
de fait tout utilisateur vous le
confirmera les fichiers amazon ne
peuvent être plus que sur pc grâce à un
logiciel amazon ou de clips de temps sur
iphone en douterez terme amazon
verrouille son marché et il va
maintenant vous dire que nous on n'est
pas pour la libre concurrence
donc je le dis à vouloir trop défendre
ce principe de libre concurrence
les députés n'ont pas vu que au
contraire ils installent une situation
ubuesque où cette concurrence est
précisément mise à mal le président de
la fnac alexandre bompard ne sied pas
trompé qui a estimé qu'une loi visant
uniquement les entreprises nationales
entraînerait inc ablement leur
disparition
puisqu'elle ne pourrait faire face
efficacement aux offres des compagnies
étrangères
déjà en position dominante sur le marché
affaibli à nos entreprises et renforcer
la concurrence déloyale voilà simplement
le résultat annoncé d'une mesure que
peut-être n'ont pas bien vu des députés
et je salue le fait que le rapporteur
maintient que nous maintenons et que
nous rentrons à nouveau en dialogue avec
l'assemblée pour pouvoir et espéré les
convainque s'ils veulent bien considérer
que le sénat peut des fois avoir raison
avant eux
je veux ensuite et c'est dommage parce
que j'ai plus de temps mais quand même
l'évoquer la question des auteurs c'est
un amendement oui que j'ai proposé je
suis très heureux qu'il a été non
seulement repris mais qu'il est bien
défendue ici puisqu'il est remis dans le
texte
je voudrais dire quand même que il est
absolument incompréhensible de la part
des éditeurs qu'il puisse nous dire
qu'un article qui vise que quand il y
aura économies de coûts et dont une plus
grande manne globale pour l'ensemble de
la chaîne de l'édition que les auteurs
puissent bénéficier d'une rémunération
juste et équitable
j'ai trop entendu dans cet hémicycle
défendent une loi pourtant que je
combattais la loi hadopi
au nom de la défense des auteurs et de
la crasse ou pour qu'aujourd'hui on
vient de me dire que les auteurs sont
maintenant parler dans une noire et que
finalement c'est pas le sujet je peux
vous faire la démonstration et je le
ferai en tout à l'heure dans la
discussion sur les amendements puisque
j'ai plus de temps mais il est évident
que là où le marché april etats unis
canada japon
les économies de coûts sont très
importants il faut que les auteurs sans
remettre en cause le cadre contractuel
personnel qu'ils ont avec l'éditeur
puisse s'appuyer sur un socle qui dit
seulement une chose bête leur
rémunération doit être juste et
équitable
et ce n'est pas renvoyé cette question
un rapport comme on sait quand on veut
balayer la question comme l'a fait
l'assemblée nationale qui pouvait nous
rassurer je suis heureux que dans ceux
dans cette loi telle qu'elle nous est
proposé à nouveau au sénat par madame
leur apporterait par notre commission et
bien nous puissions non seulement voter
pour mais être ensemble pour mener ce
combat de conviction vers nos collègues
de l'assemblée nationale merci mon cher
collègue là par l'état français aux
labos pour le groupe rdse
c'est françoise
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
l'arrivée du numérique bouscule
l'économie du livre la numérisation
massive pose non seulement la question
de la protection de l'ensemble des
droits d'auteur pardon mais aussi celle
acteurs traditionnels de la chaîne du
livre potentiellement en danger
bien que le marché du livre numérique
soit encore balbutiant nous assistons
déjà une mutation commerciale sans
précédent dont les conséquences sont
loin d'être neutres sur le plan culturel
et dont les effets vont être
exponentielle dans les mois et les
années à venir
la proposition de loi sur le prix du
livre numérique que nous examinons
aujourd'hui en deuxième lecture répond à
l'objectif primordial de la préservation
de la diversité culturelle en proposant
une régulation du secteur
néanmoins il est important de fixer un
cadre légal qui soit suffisamment souple
pour accompagner l'évolution
technologique
c'est la meilleure solution pour éviter
d'être prise au dépourvu par la vague du
numérique
l'article 7 du texte fisc une clause de
revoyure rendez vous législatifs annuel
permettant d'observer l'évolution des
pratiques du marché et d'étudier son
impact sur l'ensemble de la filière
ainsi nous pourrons nous adapter au fur
et à mesure à ce nouveau mode de
consommation de la culture qui nous
semble encore très virtuel certaines
dispositions adoptées par l'assemblée
nationale
introduire de la souplesse en permettant
de tenir compte des spécificités des
offres proposées à des fins d'usagé
collectif ou professionnels grâce à
l'instauration d'un cadre de négociation
des prix approprié à ses usages cela
concerne notamment les établissements
publics de diffusion du savoir et de la
connaissance comme les publier au tec
universitaires et de recherche
c'est une excellente disposition je me
réjouis par ailleurs que la commission
de la culture du sénat et ré introduit
l'obligation de fixer un prix de vente
pour les états
éditeurs établis hors de france et
commercialisant leurs livres sur le
territoire français l'assemblée
nationale était revenu en première
lecture sur cette disposition introduite
au sénat
de façon tout à fait consensuelle nous
avons décidé en commission de la
rétablir et c'est une excellente
nouvelle
comment imaginer ne pas aborder dans ce
contexte l'extraterritorialité ou encore
la reconnaissance d'une rémunération
équitable pour les auteurs ces deux
problèmes sont majeurs l'un comme
l'autre avaient été écartés par nos
collègues députés de la majorité
espérons que notre persévérance unanime
l'emportera et que ces dispositions
survivront à la navette législative
enfin je tiens à remercier le président
jacques legendre ainsi que notre
collègue catherine dumas pour leur
initiative
la proposition de loi que nous allons
adopter est le fruit attendus de longue
réflexion et concertation
face à la montée en puissance du livre
numérique passé de 0,1 pour cent du
chiffre d'affaires du marché du livre en
2008 à 1,5 pour cent aujourd'hui il
fallait réagir vite pour équipe réserve
et l' équilibre déjà fragile de ce
secteur depuis la première lecture du
texte au sénat nous avons l'occasion le
22 novembre dernier lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de finances pour 2011 de
favoriser l'émergence de ce marché en
adoptant un amendement en faveur de la
baisse de la tva sur le livre numérique
passant de 19 6% à 5,5 comme pour les
livres papiers au nom de la défense
d'une certaine exception française en
matière culturelle
le gouvernement a fini par se rallier à
cette proposition
prévue au 1er janvier 2012 l'extension
du taux réduit dépendra des négociations
européennes
l'objectif est donc de convaincre
l'europe qui pour l'instant exclue
toujours les services fournis par voie
électronique du bénéfice de la tva
minoré avec l'espoir de réussir à
généraliser une tva réduite sur
l'ensemble des services culturels en
ligne
de la vidéo à la musique en passant par
la presse monsieur le ministre nous
espérons beaucoup
les négociations entre la commission
européenne les états membres et monsieur
jacques toubon nommé ambassadeur
itinérant sur ce sujet le débat sur la
dématérialisation du livre et de la
culture doit nécessairement avoir lieu à
l'échelle internationale car en matière
des changes immatériel les frontières
physiques ne sont plus pertinentes
d'ailleurs en la matière force est de
constater que le livre numérique
constitue une opportunité formidable
pour la démocratisation de l'accès à la
culture et à la lecture
il est donc fondamental de se servir dès
maintenant de cette question
c'est la raison pour laquelle une grande
majorité des membres du groupe rdse
votera cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci monsieur
collègues dans le fil de la discussion
générale de la parole de votre collègue
jack ralite pour le groupe crc spg
cette présidence le ministre mes chers
collègues
cette proposition de loi un objectif
fondamental pour l'avenir de la filière
du livre numérique
transposée pour partie les dispositions
vertueuse de la loi lang de 1981 portant
prix unique pour le livre comme pour le
livre papier
il s'agit d'empêcher que le marché du
livre numérique soit accaparée par de
grands groupes financiers mondiaux qui
bras dans les livres comme une
marchandise ordinaire aurait raison
acteurs moins important et plus modestes
jouant un rôle essentiel dans la vie
diversité la qualité de l'offre
éditoriale française et de sa diffusion
afin que google amazon ou apple
noren en maître sur l'offre éditoriale
numérique française il est indispensable
d'instaurer à prix unique du livre c'est
que c'est par l'éditeur pour ce nouveau
support
le livre est davantage définie par son
contenu que par son support il est avant
tout une oeuvre de l'esprit et peut
s'incarner différemment sur papier ou
bien numériquement sans que sange
sa caractéristique fondamentale le livre
est un bien culturel et la france doit
réaffirmer l'exception culturelle
c'est un combat à mener sans relâche
plus que jamais alors que l'intérêt
privé et financier des grands groupes se
place au dessus de l'intérêt général
c'est le devoir du législateur de fixer
par le droit les limites à la
concurrence dit libre est bel et bien
fossé il est vrai que cette loi peine à
définir son objet même impossible de
répondre à cette question simple qu'est
ce qu'un livre numérique objets naissant
que la pratique n'a pas encore défini on
s'en fait une idée approximative
ce texte fait d'ailleurs un peu la vue
son ignorance puisqu'il vise le livre
numérique homothétique soit l'équivalent
du livre papier sous un autre format
alors que l'intérêt même du numérique
réside
dans l'ajout de fonctionnalités propres
c'est une insuffisance que doit
néanmoins affronter la loi sous peine de
ne plus produire d'effet dans un marché
tendant à être régulier par les géants
commerciaux du verbe
on ne peut qu'espérer qu'elle ne manque
pas son objet et que le comité de suivi
prévue pour la résoudre avec ses
rapports annuels désormais l'avenir de
ce texte se concentre sur deux questions
quelle rémunération garantie pour
l'auteur une question centrale à l'heure
du livre numérique
nous devons impérativement en faire
mention dans la loi quel périmètre
d'application la loi dont elle concerner
tous les prestataires de livres en
france quel que soit leur lieu
l'établissement ou bien se restreindre
aux seuls facteurs résidant sur le sol
français
cette deuxième solution est aussi
inutile que dangereuse inutile car ces
lois ne toucheraient aucun des trois
géants qui s'empare de ce marché
naissant
alors que ce devrait être son objet même
amazon google et apple
aucun établis en france et dans le cas
contraire viennent les empêche de se
délocaliser les frontières physiques
n'ont guère d'importance à la
circonstance
ou plutôt elles en ont mais davantage en
termes de fiscalité que de rayonnement
cela est également dangereux car le
marché du livre serait régi par une
double législation un peu unique
s'imposeraient aux entreprises
françaises et un prix non ils mentent et
à toutes les autres dont il est certain
qu elles envahiront le marché français
du livre numérique
si les membres de la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale disent leur
adhésion aux objectifs qui ont suivi
notre prétendu consensus
il vide dans un même temps la loi de son
effectivité en limitant son application
seuls acteurs établis sur le territoire
français ils choisissent d'appliquer les
lois du marché à ce bien culturel
ils réduisent la loi à une simple
déclaration d'intention qui n'aura
malheureusement pas de vertus
incantatoire le sénat a étendu en
première lecture ils perdent
l'application de cette loi à tous les
acteurs qui commercialise en france
quels qu'ils soient je me félicite que
nous rétablissions l'ex territoriale
extra territorialité de l'application de
cette loi malgré les modifications de
l'assemblée nationale nous ne devons pas
céder sur ce point ni sur celui de la
rémunération des auteurs
les arguments de la majorité de
l'assemblée nationale s'appuie sur le
droit communautaire notamment dans la
directive services est celle sur le
commerce électronique
la législation européenne semble avoir
en tout lieu et pour toute chose c'est
des homos du marché et même avoir été
créée pour mieux le faire fonctionner
elle dirige l intérêt général et
culturel courant d'exception pourtant
cela n'a jamais empêché la france d'être
porteuse initiative de combat lesquels
ont souvent été mené avec justesse
bénéficiant à la richesse et la
diversité de la création culturelle
il faut ici une volonté forte et
combative si la france ne lacarne pas
alors qu'ils les décisions de l'europe
ne doivent pas tomber comme un couperet
mais être révisée quand nécessaire
directive services et commerce
électronique qui régissent le livre
numérique doivent prendre en compte
l'exception d'intérêt général fondée sur
des impératifs culturel un premier
combat de feu est menée actuellement le
droit européen considère la vente de
livres numériques sur internet comme un
service et non comme un bien à l'instar
du livre papier c'est biaisé sa
conception en se focalisant sur le
support du livre et non sur sa
caractéristique fondamentale de création
littéraire de la une distinction de
droit qui n'a pas lieu d'être
sans compter qu'il examen consciencieux
des deux avis rendu par la commission
européenne
servant d' arguments aux opposants à
l'extra territorialité montre qu'il n'ya
guère matière matière à renoncer
premièrement que la loi fasse mention ou
non de l'extraterritorialité les
décisions rendues au niveau européen
actuellement à propos de ce texte sont
strictement les mêmes
on voit donc mal
en quoi supprimer cette clause est
nécessaire puisque dans les deux cols ou
apporterait atteint je cite la liberté
d'établissement la libre prestation des
services ainsi qu'à la directive
e-commerce si remise en cause il ya par
la commission
je le dis comme je le pense c'est le
principe du prix unique dans sa
globalité
deuxièmement la commission n'affirme pas
définitivement la contradiction de la
loi avec le droit européen
elle évoque la nécessité d'argumentation
de la france sur l'adéquation et la
proportionnalité des mesures aux
objectifs désignés
on est surpris de cette frilosité à
affronter d'éventuelles mécontentement
de bruxelles dans le domaine du prix du
livre numérique alors que nous nous en
sommes parfaitement en français
concernant l'extension de l'application
d'un taux de tva réduit 5,5 pour cent du
livre papier au livre numérique ce qui
vient au monde pour ne rien troubler le
mérite ni égard ni patience disait rené
char il faut que nous portions une
volonté politique forte pour défendre
une fois de plus les politiques
culturelles afin que progresser valeur
au sein de l'union européenne
la convention de l'unesco sur la
protection et la promotion de la
diversité des expressions culturelles
d'octobre 2005 promeut la diversité
culturelle et linguistique et fournit
des bases juridiques ou maintien de la
richesse d'une offre éditoriale protégés
que je trouve pour ma part un peu molle
songeons article 20 où se trouve un méli
mélo des positions contradictoires entre
l'unesco et l'om sait mais même
imparfaite la convention l'esprit qui
l'entourent reste un outil dont il faut
s'emparer
je suis satisfait de votre position
monsieur le ministre
au récent salon du livre en faveur de la
clause d'extraterritorialité vous est
clair en disant que le prix unique doit
s'appliquer joue site à l'ensemble des
ventes de livres numériques effectuées
en france
quel que soit le lieu d'implantation des
opérateurs vous avez été clair dans
votre présentation du problème tout à
l'heure tout comme madame b beau
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
culturelles unanime à ceux qui renoncent
avant de se battre je rappelle que
google continue de sévir aux états unis
en foulant aux pieds le droit d'auteur
pourtant à l'américaine et
qu'heureusement le juge lui tient tête
je rappelle qu amazon est dit-on à
l'origine des percussions un peu musclé
début mars de plusieurs maisons
d'édition françaises par la commission
européenne
enfin gallimard qui vient de fêter son
centenaire a été visité je n'ai qu'une
envie le gouvernement français doit
suivre son ministre de la culture qui
rencontre le désir des professionnels et
auteur qui ne doivent pas se laisser
diviser et entendre la répétition du
sénat dans ses positions de première
lecture en deuxième lecture multiplier
les jeux sans viser le nous est une
impasse face à une redoutable cleaver
sachant nous distinguer oui mais en même
temps nous relier et cela sans crampes
mental
merci mon cher collègue dans la suite
des risques sur gerald la parole et à
catherine morin desailly pour le groupe
union centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre madame le rapporteur mes très
chers collègues 1981 2011 voilà
pratiquement 30 ans et vous l'avez
rappelé le ministre que le parlement a
adopté la loi lang instaurant un prix
unique du livre en france
trois décennies plus tard lorsque l'on
fait le bilan
indéniablement cette loi a sauvé le
secteur du livre papier
le prix unique du livre a permis de
conserver à côté des rayons aux produits
bien standardisée des hypermarchés dieu
merci
un réseau de librairies indépendant
verra véritable médiateur culturel de
nos territoires et bien sûr une très
grande diversité éditoriale à l'heure de
lits commerce le texte dont nous
débattons essentiel puisqu'il propose
selon les préconisations du rapport
zelnik d'étendre le principe du prix
unique du livre à sa version numérique
pérennisant ainsi la chaîne du livre
aujourd'hui confrontés à des
transformations sans précédent le bilan
du dernier salon du livre nous
encouragent en ce sens
les débats qui s'y sont tenues ont
permis de faire un poids sur l'évolution
du marché de l'édition
d'ailleurs on note pour la première fois
un prix du livre numérique a été
attribué ce salon a été aussi l'occasion
de découvrir les résultats de l'étude
ipsos réalisée en janvier dernier
intitulé notoriété et usages du livre
numérique notoriété en évolution
positive depuis 2009 puisque on à 61 %
contre 47 % de lecteurs aujourd'hui
averti sur le livre numérique puis pour
cent s'y adonnent contre 5% l'année
précédente
dans l'étude ce qui est intéressant
c'est que 65 % disent que le livre
papier restera toujours le principal
support du livre je ne pense pas en
effet qu'il y aura une substitution mais
de nouveaux usages et une
complémentarité du tout simplement aux
fonctionnalités nouvelles associées aux
livres numériques livres et ebooks vont
donc contre coexister ce phénomène s'est
d'ailleurs pratiquement produit à chaque
fois qu une technologie nouvelle a été
inventé les films n'ont pas tué le
théâtre la télévision n'a pas tué le
cinéma et la radio
le marché du livre numérique est donc un
marché naissant mais prometteur qu'il
convient non seulement de réguler mais
aussi d'encourager à cet égard comme
vous le savez c'est le sénat qui a
permis que soit votée à la
quasi-unanimité sauf je n'ai pas compris
ce soir là nos collègues sénateurs
socialistes de la commission des
finances qui n'ont pas voté
ce taux de tva à 5,5 sur le livre
numérique lors de la loi de finances
pour 2011
en effet j'ai eu l'honneur de défendre
notre commission cela m'était facile car
c'était également la position que mon
groupe avait défendu lors de la première
lecture
c'est un moment important permettant
qu'il n'y a aucune distorsion de
concurrence
seul moyen de garantir le développement
d'une offre légale attractive pour les
lecteurs jugeront tout d'abord cette
mesure contraire au droit européen le
gouvernement s'est finalement rallié à
notre position et a nommé jacques toubon
ambassadeur itinérant pour mener les
concertations au niveau européen afin
d'aboutir à une uniformisation de la tva
sur le livre numérique
cette affaire est temps je crois régler
au niveau de nos assemblées aujourd'hui
nous retrouvons cette fois un blocage
sur la clause d'extraterritorialité
je ne m'attarderai pas sur le sujet
plusieurs d'entre vous ayant rappelé les
divergences d'appréciation que nous
avons avec les députés nous qui avons
voulu à l'initiative de jean pierre
leleux prendre en compte la dimension
transnationale la vente de livres
numériques sur internet et la réalité de
la concurrence qui s'y exercent en
application toujours de la clause de
diversité culturelle
la commission européenne a émis des
réserves certes mais au nom de quoi je
vous le demande
les plateformes faisons commerce et
créations françaises établies hors de
france seraient exclus du champ
d'application du livre du prix unique du
livre au nom de quoi on cautionnerait
finalement des pratiques commerciales
prédatrices d'acteurs étrangers tout
puissants
monsieur le ministre vous vous êtes
exprimés ces jours-ci et sim encore à
cette tribune il ya quelques instants
et je sais que comme nous vous pensez
qu'il faut se battre et que la démarche
doit être poussé à l'échelle européenne
d'ailleurs on devra aller plus loin dans
cette perspective également insufflé à
bruxelles l'idée d'une tva à 5,5 pour
tous les véhicules
thür elle aussi bien la vidéo la musique
ou encore la presse en ligne et ceci
dans l'ensemble des pays membres face à
ces questions que nous sommes plus
largement posée lors de la loi de
finances ces questions d'évasion fiscale
que représente aujourd'hui
l'installation de certains opérateurs au
luxembourg ou en irlande
nous devons en effet nous interroger sur
le rôle que doit jouer l'europe pour la
diversité culturelle à l'heure du
numérique sur la manière dont elle doit
concevoir la survie de ce qui constitue
son patrimoine et son héritage mais
aussi l'originalité de sa création il
faut que sans arrogance mais avec force
et détermination locution continuer à
défendre l'idée que le livre quelle que
soit sa forme ou son support n'est pas
tant une marchandise ou un service en
ligne 15 biens culturels précieux un
bientôt il faut préserver la diversité
en matière d'offre car que faut-il
défendre en fait l'intérêt du
consommateur soit disant en l'espèce
avantagé par la libre concurrence ou
l'intérêt de ce que vous préférez
appeler masser demi nice le lecteur vous
l'avez dit l'économie du livre c'est
quand même autre chose que celle de la
lessive ou d'un paquet de céréales et
comme l'a souligné thierry tu aux
membres du collège de l'autorité de la
concurrence
l'objectif n'est pas d'avoir le prix le
plus bas mais d'abord le prix le plus
juste qui permette aux acteurs de la
chaîne de valeur de retrouver juste
rémunération et aux lecteurs internautes
d'accéder aux biens dans des conditions
normales
c'est important car la législation
française et particulièrement dans le
domaine culturel est observé dans le
monde entier
vous l'avez suggéré monsieur le ministre
qui rentrait d'un déplacement aux états
unis au cours duquel vous avez pu
rencontrer les représentants d'apple
google et amazon et leur affirmer votre
attachement au présent texte vous avez
d'ailleurs indiqué que google et apple
semblerait plus ouvert qu'à ma zone sur
la position française
si ce texte nous permet de poser les
bases d'un modèle économique
il est aussi un encouragement pour tous
les acteurs à s'organiser afin d'assurer
une juste rémunération des éditeurs des
auteurs des libraires ils savent qu'il
est dans l'intérêt de tous de se
structurer rapidement afin de faire face
aux risques hégémonique
d apple google et amazon certaines
initiatives sont déjà prometteuse
il a été cité notamment le portail 1000
et à libraire point cob qui fédère 300
librairies indépendantes et dont le
service de géolocalisation des stocks
présentent un réel avantage
concurrentiel face à ses plateformes
je suis satisfaite que le texte issu de
la commission veille aussi assurer la
défense du droit d'auteur dans l'univers
numérique
car l'absence de fabrication de stockage
et de transport dans la production et la
diffusion de livres numériques exigent
une révélation des parvenant aux
éditeurs et aux auteurs
à cet égard permettez moi malgré tout
deux souligné que que l'on veuille ou
non les évolutions technologiques des
produits que ce soit les contenus les
outils les accès vont certainement
entraîner l'apparition de nouveaux
modèles économiques et obliger les
acteurs du secteur eux mêmes à s'adapter
n'y aurait-il pas par exemple la
tentation de certains à éviter les
intermédiaires notamment l'éditeur ou le
libraire et que demain auteurs traitent
directement avec un distributeur
électronique
j'avais tenu à souligner en première
lecture également que s'il faut
préserver un écosystème éditorial il
fallait aussi prendre en compte la
spécificité des acteurs du monde des
creative commons
ces logiciels collaboratifs libre et
ouvert ce texte
en tout cas nécessaire est une première
brique et ne construit pas toute la
maison
aujourd'hui nous statuons sur le livre
homothétique définition vestra excluant
les créations numériques
très vite les technologies de pointe
telles que la réalité augmentée
permettront yves papier de se
transformer en livre vivant et
tridimensionnelle et d'évoluer vers des
contenus multimédias ses oeuvres enrichi
par l'interactivité poseront de
nouvelles questions notamment en matière
de juste rémunération
quel sera le paysage culturel du monde
dans les 30 ans qui viennent
nous ne devons pas oublier que
l'histoire de l'écrit a connu de
nombreuses évolutions techniques qui ont
entraîné des mutations culturelles
économiques qui fondent notre société
actuelle
dans cette dynamique la numérisation ne
signe pas la fin du livre mais plutôt ce
renouveau contemporain aussi en dépit de
quelques petites réserves émises nous
voterons ce texte rétablit par les
sénateurs dans sa version issue de notre
première lecture gageons qu'il nous
permette de préserver cet objet si
particulier qu'est le livre c'est victor
hugo y disait la lumière est dans le
livre
ouvrez le livre tout grand laissez-le
rayonner laissez le faire
vous venez de suivre une partie de la
discussion consacrée à la proposition de
loi sur le prix du livre numérique si
vous souhaitez revoir cette discussion
notre site internet publicsenat.fr merci
de votre fidélité très belle journée à
tous
savez vous ce qui se passe en irak
aujourd'hui pas vraiment ce pays qui a
été à la une de l'actualité pendant des
années est en train de passer aux
oubliettes et pourtant il y a toujours
dix attentats par jour à bagdad après
l'occupation américaine
où va l'irak vers la paix ou le chaos
c'est le thème du docu débat cette
semaine sur public sénat elise lucet
présente le débat samedi à 23h sur
public sénat